all right great to be back on CNN happy
New Year we've got with us today the guy
who hosts msnbc's de beat with Ari
melber Ari melber is over here and he
writes the weekly dish newsletter Andrew
Sullivan
okay uh all right Ari what do you make
of the recent study that found that half
of inflation in the US oh yes I saw this
is due to high corporate profits they're
calling this greed flation which I think
is right I mean what impact does greed
inflation have on our economy right so
people you know there was a legitimate
reason why Prices rose for a while but
then of course they used that as excuse
to raise the prices now that stuff is
coming down somehow the prices don't
come down too because the profits are
fat now yeah the price couching is
documented they brag about it earnings
calls to Wall Street it's allowed um
there are other places that make it much
harder France has rules that actually
make this a lot harder to do but here
it's legal but it's outrageous um and at
the time they're giving themselves big
pay raises in the in the boardroom too
well here's my question is what do you
do about it I remember two things Gavin
and I talked for a second about
jawboning I mean presidents did that in
the past they literally just did it by
the power of presidential coercion they
got people in the Oval Office and they
said look you Knuckleheads you're doing
something bad for the country and
sometimes that worked Nixon as I recall
maybe I got this wrong but I think he
had price controls I mean L that's
something very foreign even I don't
barely remember that that we would
actually work and they don't work in the
long run right um look the best way to
bring prices down is competition right
so if if these companies if the if
there's a cartel involved in keeping
prices High when they should be going
down then the cartel needs to be broken
up I don't haven't read the study so I
don't know but but it's not like
inflation hasn't been explained by a
variety of factors obviously the the the
the supply side stuff the constrained
supply of goods then you had the big
overspending of the Biden stimulus which
really did I understand why they did it
and they they got a good deal of growth
from it but they did uh some some of it
came out in inflation and was Trum to
absolutely everybody yeah got together
to spend $6 trillion dollar to lock
ourselves in but what's interesting now
is the most
resilient high prices are of food
right yes and I is the is is food
corporations bragging about this well
yeah they are in the earnings calls
because they they don't think they're
really going to get heard that much
they're even doing it on diaper sales
and it's not a cartel but there aren't a
lot of diaper providers so if the three
main companies that do it on the
national basis then no there's no price
there are certain products you can't
live without I'm sure if you have
someone who needs diapers Li either at
the beginning or end of life you
definitely want sure I mean like I
always hear people always have people
about plumbers you know they
charge an arm and a leg have you ever
ever needed a plumber if if plumbers
only knew what we would pay them
yeah when it's coming up through your
bedroom okay uh Andrew this is for you
what are your thoughts about the Pope's
recent declaration that sexual pleasure
is a gift from God thanks Big
Man and but
that but that pornography must be
avoided well that's
contradictory no I'm kidding um he's
he's stating actually Catholic Doctrine
when we're not supposed to hate our
sexual pleasure we're not supposed to I
mean this is not the case with
Protestants of course but Catholics were
allowed right I remember when I first
realized I had this between my legs it
was the best day of my entire life
and and I never really could understand
it as a sin uh uh masturbation and that
pleasure was just something that de so
obviously self-evidently natural and
great why would God be punishing me for
it and I actually as I was very devout I
just decided Well that's obviously not
true the way I decided that well the
Virgin Mary wasn't physically ascended
into heaven um there were certain things
you said okay no that's not right I
remember when I was first masturbating
and I did not know what it was we didn't
have I didn't either I and I remember
thinking is this bad for me
but then it was
[Applause]
like really it was like I I I didn't
know really I thought it was urine I did
it in the dark and the only thing I'd
ever seen come out of there was urine I
know and it seemed like this doesn't
seem right
but the fact that you remember that
moment I remember that moment too just
shows you how natural it is and how
naive we were compared to kids today CU
I'm sure they know everything before
they're seven years old they do and I
there was no porn either like I used to
honestly I had a scrapbook I would draw
the dudes I wanted to have sex with
that's all I could do draw them and but
that meant that my imagination was kind
of set off when I first discovered sex
it was like oh this is interesting that
is interesting now you meet like someone
who's 21 they're like well I'd like you
to be Daddy with a bad report card we
need to be there with a with a with a
spanker and show up at this point and
wear this and I'm like where did you get
this from okay um
got to remember we're on CNN not not
Club random
[Applause]
uh uh for panel who do you think Trump
has on his short list for VP well
stefanic is the one that was talked
about now the she's the isn't that the
one that they were talking she's the New
York State used to be a normal and then
became Trump crazy and the Tormentor of
Claudine gay yes that's that's what
that's what makes s but I think still
Haley I mean Trump has teamed up I think
he's teamed up with people who've said
way worse things JD Vance wrote a whole
book and launched his career attacking
Trump He does care he doesn't care about
any of that and Haley uh although there
are parts of Mag as we discussed that
might not love her if Trump says this is
it and he's very practical and she would
help in the suburbs which is his biggest
general election vulnerability I think
there's a lot of the actual numbers
people around Trump who are trying to
get him think about that and it would it
would probably give him several points I
saw I saw in the paper this week that he
is doing better and did better with
college educat I remember when he won
Iowa or was running in Iowa in 2016 and
he had that famous line I love the
poorly
educated I mean you can't write this you
said bill you said tonight that it looks
like he could get reelected he
definitely could but he got 3 million
fewer votes in 16 he got 7 million fewer
votes in 20 and they had bad midterms
and the Democrat have won every
state-based special election the last
year if he's going to win which he could
he can't run as the 20 or 16 version of
him and the ticket is the first largest
way to say to the suburb I'm a little
different talk Politics the trouble with
Nikki is that she is she makes sort of
Dick Cheney look like the delai Lama I
mean there is not
a there is not a country she would
invade not a region she wouldn't bomb
she is the most NE most unreconstructed
neocon I've ever come across in politics
and Trump's entire message is I'm not an
unreconstructed neocon I I think the
base you're parsing you're giving the
voters way too much credit like they are
looking at neocon versus not they don't
this is not what they're thinking
about I I think no this is why I get
back to the issues with Trump no I think
one of the issues that helped him was
people were sick of these wars and when
they have someone who seems they want to
get into more Wars they were not going
to like it it's a big issue I don't
think voters expect the running mate to
set foreign policy period I I I don't
think they think about foreign policy
the hell of a lot except if it the one
that they care about now is Ukraine
because it's holding up immigration
reform they care about this country
what's going on in this country just the
way most people watch local news they
don't watch national news me they don't
want the wars which Nikki represents
that's what the that's their position on
foreign policy we don't want to have one
really yeah the median Trump voter
doesn't think that he's going to take
the cues from her on that or that that's
really the issue they're voting on Nikki
Haley what is she going to do about
Pakistan I I just don't think this is
this I don't know
what um all right I have time for one
more oh I see they're going after Alec
Baldwin again for the shooting at is
this not the most ridiculous thing I
mean does anyone think Alec Baldwin
purposely shot that person if not what
is this about if if he if it was an
accident it was there was a horrible
accident accidents happen maybe this is
some sort of manslaughter thing but
certainly he didn't go give me a loaded
gun I want to shoot the cinematographer
I feel this is ridiculous you want a
legal view yes yeah it's very
overcharged uh and it's hard to imagine
charging a normal random citizen a non-f
famous citizen twice on this theory of
the case now legally the prosecutors say
well look as an involuntary manslaughter
we don't have to improve uh approve
deliberate intent we're saying it was so
reckless and a life was lost and that's
tragic and it is a terrible tragedy and
obviously some a lot has to change on
however that set was ever run um but I
don't think based on how it looks and
what we know again always if more
evidence came out that a citizen a
non-famous person would be double
charged like this it seems very extreme
okay that's it run out of time thank you
CNN thank you audience thank you P we'll
see you next week good to be
back